monsieur le président vos réponses sont
évidemment à satisfaisante
huit ministres ont déjà démissionné pour
cause d'affaires
cela commence à bien suffire c'est bien
de dire il y à des erreurs il n'y a
aucun responsable
le service le secrétariat général du
gouvernement dépend du premier ministre
les services du premier ministre doivent
en informer le premier ministre
c'est le principe est là quelles sont
les conséquences que le premier ministre
en a tiré je me le demande fortement
tout le monde s'inquiète des procédure
orale alors que vous le savez bien
monsieur le ministre que pour cumuler
quand vous êtes fonctionnaire une
rémunération accessoires sur des
activités limitée par la loi
il faut une autorisation expresse écrite
alors où sont les écrits quelles sont
les erreurs qu'elles sont les
dysfonctionnements vous avez fait voter
une loi en juillet 2017 pour la
transparence et sans arrêt cette loi est
violée par votre gouvernement
pire c'est la constitution qui a été
bafoué alors personne ne sait il ya des
erreurs des ignorants alors dans le
monde de jupiter
relisez la fontaine relisez la fontaine
qui dit rien n'est plus dangereux qu'un
ignorant tami mieux vaut à sage ennemis
merci
[Musique]